of course it wasn't the intention to
launch prestige in a recession the
intentional launch at this year before
the recession was predicted or or came
about that the extended has come about
having said that I still don't think
it's a bad idea I think the very rich
will always be at least rich arm and the
lifestyles of these people which is very
cosmopolitan very international very
curious very active very alpha in some
ways that doesn't change only the
numbers change so this is the magazine
about that lifestyle it'll carry the
advertising for products and services
and lifestyles that the rich can still
afford yes for sure everybody's being a
bit more sober about excessive spending
including us at the magazine but you
know in general the lifestyle still
valid and still of interest to this
demographic so in natural facts may be
one of the few good launches in a
timeline